getting ready to have a shower to go for
my morning meeting
and i open the the suitcase and i say
holy who's i
see a clown suit and i see i'm the idiot
that did i always wondered who are the
idiots that take someone else's suitcase
and it says it's me
[Music]
elisa pellick thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders good
morning
hi good morning great to be with you
it's fantastic to have you here
first off you know we were so we know
each other for many many years we were
recently
reintroduced through j ventures but the
very first thing that i that i saw about
you is that you're a board member of
asian box
which like i mentioned is one of my
favorite restaurants of all time based
in california
so so thank you for making it happen and
for allowing me to have such a
such a great meal obviously it's a it's
a
just one of many many things that you're
doing i can't wait to talk about your
career
and and some of the insights that you've
gained and give me a second just give a
brief introduction as to
some of the incredible things you've
done and then i'll let you take it from
there
but starting out as developer relations
for the mac platform all the way back in
91 with apple
to being a manager managing director at
sap to head of global planning and
operations at better and better place
uh one of the most revolutionary and
innovative
companies that spun out of israel with
obvious great support of shimon peres
chief operating officer of planet soho
gm
at nice uh chief operating officer at
reality
and board and now board members of both
ayew software and asian box elisa
incredible incredible career but before
we get into that
you mentioned you have a fun story to
share with me
well first of all thank you for that
great introduction
and it just shows you how many years i
go back
and uh and i have to thank you for being
a loyal customer
of uh of asian box it's been it's been
tough
during the covert the season and trying
to keep the service
going and feeding our amazing customers
with this very fresh and organic and
gluten-free food
is is indeed a challenge but we've been
rewarded by the
by the phenomenal support of our
customers and keep it up and spread the
word
and we love your support so thanks a
million and that's really
probably the only thing that i've done
in my career which is not
tech or software related right so so
it's an interesting it's a it's a
wonderful phenomenal
a phenomena um as for an interesting
story you know i'm
i'm sure that there are tons the one
that comes to my mind
is that i actually had a breakfast
meeting
with a cfo of a fortune
500 with my pajamas
so what is that how does that happen how
does that happen
um so um one of those
five a.m uh flights
that means you leave your house at two
o'clock in the morning and you pack a
suitcase
and i fly quite often so i i fly what i
call in my pajamas which is just
the worst sweats the most comfortable
t-shirt
and sneakers and just to be able to
sleep in the flight
and um and this is pre-business class
where they give you pajamas this is
sitting in coach with my own
t-shirt and sweats and i fly for a
meeting
in the morning with the cfo and i land
at the airport
and i didn't believe this would ever
happen to me i took someone else's
suitcase
wow which looked exactly like mine i
traveled an
hour to the hotel getting ready to have
a shower to go for my morning
meeting and i open the the suitcase and
i say holy who's i
see a clown suit and i see i'm the idiot
that did i always wondered who are the
idiots that take someone else's suitcase
and it was like
it's me and it was
it was horrific i always wonder i always
wonder who is that person
who is the idiot that didn't check it
was exactly the same color the exact
same size
the good news is a i it had a phone
number
i called the guy and i said joe
i have your stuff don't freak out um
he uh obviously left my suitcase at this
at the
airport i immediately called the cab it
cost me
100 euros each direction to just to drop
the other suitcase
and come back with mine but there was no
time for the meeting
and i just went in my pajamas
with my sneakers with this crappy old
t-shirt and and i walked into this
beautiful immaculate office the guy is
wearing a
a white star shirt with a beautifully
tight tie
and i said i'm sorry i meant to promise
wonderful wonderful and an amazing
leeway into
into the phenomenal career that you've
had and most interestingly
you know if i'm looking at this at this
amazing list
i'm seeing a lot of vision and we talked
about this very briefly before we
started
i'm seeing companies that are really
revolutionizing
whatever industry they're in and one of
the things that i'm learning to
appreciate
both through stanford and jay ventures
is that
not is that most companies especially in
tech are not necessarily visionary or
revolutionary a lot of them are nice
they're great they're building upon
predecessors
but here i'm seeing a good cohort of
companies that are really trying to
break the mold
and do something else talk to me a
little bit about why you're attracted
to these visionary companies um
yeah that's great it's true my career
does span across
very small companies and very big
companies
startups and innovative and not so
startup and innovators also
um it's true that i that i've been
around
but i am really attracted to
to the visioneers and um
i think what led me to it was sort of
one thing to the other i'm not i'm not a
visioneer
of myself as myself um i think that um
my strengths has have always been around
execution and operation
and progress and sort of connect
connecting
the organization and grounding the
organization
to the founders vision so i think i
found myself
teaming up with with with entrepreneurs
that have a phenomenal vision but don't
necessarily
know how to connect that vision into
day to day execution by a team
that's focused that's functioning and
that allows them to
really uh and truly realize their vision
and i think
being in that environment of
entrepreneurship
and when we really really you know
fighting for our existence on a daily
basis
yet we can't just stay in the clouds and
uh and and vision without execution
um is actually not going to be a great
way to success
to succeed it takes a lot of honesty and
and courage and maturity to come and say
i
don't see myself as somebody that's
visionary but i i know that my strengths
are connecting the dots when you take
somebody with a vision
and what needs to happen in order to get
to that vision
and and and i really it inspires me
because i think that you know especially
growing around the community that i'm in
that you sort of expect every young
entrepreneur to be
visionary and all do it yourself and you
can do everything
and and having that you know honesty and
the courage to say
these are things that i'm good at these
are things that i'm not good at and i
want to capitalize on what i'm really
good at
and for you that's the world the chief
operating officer
i haven't had the pleasure of having too
many coos
on the show not nearly especially with
the background that you have here
what is the role of the operating
officer within both a small startup
and a large organization that's great
and i also want to before i go into the
details i'll also explain
and maybe there's a fun fact too it
wasn't
only that i necessarily chose that
or understood that quickly early on i
think i might have demonstrated early on
and entrepreneurs discovered that in me
and pulled me into it more than i said
this is what i do
well i did i did work with an
interpreter without mentioning names
who started the second company and
uh and wanted me to join and i said um
you know what i need
a little bit of time off between you
know i'll i'll
wait a while and i'll join you later and
he's answered to me
no worries um i'm going to start
now you can join whenever you want i
just want to make sure that you know the
later this you start
the more you'll have to clean up
then i love that okay i'll see you
monday morning
and that was the end of my time off
because i think he he he coined it
better than i so
not so nice way to describe it is to
clean up the founders or the
entrepreneurs or the visionaires
that's one part of the job
uh one way of describing it a nice
way of describing it is is really to try
and get
the machinery going ready to try and get
a rhythm right that there's a rhythm of
of planning
and executing and measuring learning
from it
moving on planning again executing
measuring and learning so
it's something to keep the organization
accountable
to we know what we're doing we're doing
it
and we said we would do it we're doing
it and we said we did it
and then we move on and have the ability
to sort of get that into some kind of a
spirit without being too bureaucratic
without being too
too slow but if if you if you don't
measure and if you don't really
understand and if you don't learn
you can get off track really really
quickly and sort of forget where
where you started and sometimes you know
the
the vision is is so far out and this
vector you have to sort of be
quite sure on the vector and now it's
okay to pivot it's okay to change
it's okay to go in a zigzag but i
believe in
in conscious zigzag and in understanding
and not being and not and proactive
zigzag versus
reactive i love that i love that so
do you see a very big difference between
the chief operating of service startup
and and that of a large company because
i'm sure there's
it's two different worlds right on one
hand you're talking about potentially
cleaning after
you know that visionaries mess and
obviously it's not because they're
messy but it's because you know part of
the role requires that
they do run quickly and they try
different things they break things
and you need to have that figure that
comes and says okay let's put some order
here and
and make sure that we're that we're
keeping that we're aligning to our
vision
so what so what what are the sort of the
distinctions between the two
well first they are distinctions and i
would just for the sake of clarity
i wasn't a ceo in large companies in
larger companies i was more
a gm or a managing director of a big
unit so that was more of an overall
business leadership role over
over either a line of business
you know nice i managed the 200 million
line of business
or at sap i was the head of i was the
managing director of sap labs in the us
which was the largest lab outside of
germany
and i also let and i also led the the
lab network which was seven labs
outside of germany so that was a kind of
an operating
so that's an operating role but it's not
the ceo
in the startup world i think it really
depends you know it's not appropriate
for a startup with seven people in the
garage
right and you're just figuring out your
product and you don't really have
product market fit
and you're still breaking things that's
not really when you have a co
but when you've developed a product
and we'll talk about better place
separately because that was really from
day one
we were three people in the company
really started
it started in my living room we ran the
company for six months out of my house
you know that's that's a that's a
different that's a different we'll talk
about that but
if we talk about the general level of um
of startups you know if you're i've been
mainly in the software world so
if you're six five or six people
developing a small
or a huge product but it's just the
beginning and you're breaking and you're
not sure
and but once you start uh
and when you say the word scaling it's
it's scary because you can scale in
hundreds of millions you can also scale
from
from five people to 15 people but if you
if you understand that um
you're lacking some huge capabilities
around
people management process management go
to market management so
there's becoming a little bit more
functions that are beyond the
development
the ceo is not the only guy who's doing
the sales
right you know and and and you either
the the
co or the founding team uh take this
upon themselves
you know they really understand we need
to start thinking about i'll go to
market we need to think about
hiring we need to think about culture we
need to think about processes
if they have that kind of talent then
there's no need for a ceo
at early stages but when you need when
you feel you know one guy
is really the architect and the other
guy is the head of the development and
one guy can
sort of talk to investors and everything
else is falling apart
in person you know in in in the process
in the machinery
in the hiring in in the hr in
finance then you then you know then you
start
thinking about is there is there a
person who can
aggregate all this sort of stuff
together and run it and then if you
start going to customer success and you
have support and you have go to
yeah so the more functions you go
depends very much on the composition and
the talent of the
the founders that's it that's
fascinating elisa
i have to hear the the founding of of
better health out of your living room
uh i i can't imagine anybody listening
to this who doesn't know what better
help is but
better place sorry better better place
sorry better play time
alone is a great friend and i've been
talking to him a lot in
better health is also fantastic company
also phenomenal company but better place
is is remarkable because it really is
an innovation through necessity a a
revolutionary story within israel of
course with it with the
with the late shimon peres is a huge
supporter and i remember growing up i
think i was maybe 13
14 when it was when when i started
seeing it roll out and the big headlines
and
and really what people were excited
about was how revolutionary it was
and here you have some really courageous
people with a very courageous leader
in the government that are running
together to really change the way we
think about
you know consuming fuel and how cars run
on the road and
moving to a green planet talk to me a
little bit about better place
first of all it's amazing that you know
so much about it and you're a young boy
and it's great and you spoke so
beautifully about the company you should
have been part of our team
probably even even when you were 12 or
13 years old so um
that's great it was it was absolutely a
phenomenal experience unfortunately it
crashed badly and there's a whole
session and i actually ran a small
case study at stanford for six four five
years
yes i run an annual case about
the the rise and fall of better place
wow
but but an incredible incredible leader
and a phenomenal visioneer
and we can all talk about the billion
dollar crash i want to for a second uh
put a plug-in that i think that um shia
gossi
the the founder the visioneer and the
leader
i would say uh probably single-handedly
pushed the industry to a point
that that's why we see um
so many evs around the world
the system didn't work the change in the
work we made a lot of mistakes or the
vision was 100
right but if i can give credit to him
uh the single largest credit that i can
give
him is that i think that he
single-handedly
pushed in push the industry in his
confidence
in his arrogance in his lack of humility
he walked into the heads of all the auto
makers and said if you don't do evs
you're gonna die in 2007
in 2007 we went to the frankfurt auto
show
and there wasn't one ev on the floor
or even a prototype or even a demo call
or nothing by 2010 or 11
there wasn't a manufacturer in the
entire world
that didn't have an ev story or an ev
platform or an ev strategy or something
and
and that i think i think he shy himself
and better place
as as his wing i think i i think really
really moved it
even elon musk at that time um
who was already close to delivering the
roadstar
um and delivered the roadster even at
that time
didn't publicly say i don't want to take
away from his vision at all
you know that that the entire world
should move to eevee he was he was
he was demonstrating that if you're a
porsche lover
you can do that with an ev and uv is not
a golf cart
and you can have the best and fastest
and greatest car but
mass consumption mass scale
no one spoke about and shy really
believed that that that could happen
so that um now the reason
in better place there was a head of
operations from day one
because that was
a huge undertaking it was obvious that
shy would be outbound
governments financing
regulations big outbound activities
would have zero attention and also
less capability but mainly zero
attention
to in into the company so the entire
processes
of starting to build the team
from scratch and was it and it was about
so many dimensions
because the not only the product was
complicated from
from software and hardware and batteries
and all the physics and all the
capabilities are
harder you know the market the global
expansion
the the the regulations that
managing the finance managing the people
making the legality
that we knew would be incredibly
difficult from day one
so he started with that structure that
um
we would move forward with i think
that's
that's remarkable and i think sometimes
we we tend to forget that everybody
has 24 hours in a day i remember that a
few
a few months ago somebody mentioned to
me you know we were talking about the
presidency of the united states and we
were talking about all the different
how busy they must be and the different
things they get done and then they said
you know you know the president also
has 24 hours in the day they also need
to sleep for at least
you know five or six of them and so
we're not
very different and and so i think it's
sometimes easy to forget that
you know you can't have one person who
just does it all is both a visionary
outbound inbound
and you need to have those those
different processes uh
in in place and and be very honest about
them be very
intentional about them you use the word
intentionality in the zigzag and in
operations
in the beginning of this discussion and
i love that word and
and i and i take it to heart and i'm
very excited as i go on my
entrepreneurial journey
to remind myself to continuously be
intentional about what i'm doing and who
i'm doing it with and why i'm doing it
but elisa tell me a little bit about
being a part of this of this team that
is
really educating the market educating
governments
and really going against the grain at a
time where
no other manufacturing company in
frankfurt
is showing any interest in it what is
that like
um well we had the beginning well it was
it was great it was tough it was
uh excruciating difficult but and it was
also rewarding
but it also had its challenges which
eventually led to i believe our demise
because uh and that's where you lack
the when the gap between your vision
and execution is is widening instead of
closing
and also between the story that you tell
others and the story that you tell
yourself
so i you know at some point and we'll
get to um
it's a little bit later but you know um
it was huge because we raised a lot of
money and because there were true
phenomenal believers behind it we could
tell a real great story and you
need a story in order to
to drag people governments countries
so you need a phenomenal story and we
had that
we had the money and we had good
storytellers
and i think that creates a very positive
momentum
and and sometimes it's really hard when
i think of small startups who have a
great story and they don't have
the money or the bandwidth or the
capability to actually tell it we
we sort of had um we had the privilege
to tell a huge story and the means to
tell it
loudly loudly and beautifully so
at the beginning you actually the
momentum and
and the motivation just coming from the
success of the stories that there's so
many people listening
and so many people buying into it um
so it's misleading sometimes you get
carried away you drink your own kool-aid
which is a problem in and of itself
but that's how you get going you sort of
really have to create this
this positive cycle of you tell the
story people buy the story then you
tell people that you told the story and
we also hired
phenomenal people um and
our team in israel which was led by
kaplinsky the was amazing
and their execution capability both in
the operation
building out the stations building out
the prototypes getting the
car to work an r d an r d team that i
think worked more than 24 hours a day i
have to
um i think so i think there was a lot of
small successes and progress
i wouldn't call them small that's not
fair i think there were huge progresses
in certain domains that helped us
believe that we're making
great progress but actually with such a
company
all the chain is huge there are many
links in the chain and you're only as
strong as your weakest link
and the fact that some links were
missing doesn't help the story
that takes time to to figure out and
and unfortunately at some point um i did
feel that i can't contribute anymore i
can't really fulfill my role
as i should and i decided to leave
so very very courageous and i i can't
believe that it spun out of your out of
your living room and
one of the first three people i remember
actually i was very i still am
very very good friends with one of the
children jonathan
and we spent so many many many weekends
at many many weekends at their house uh
shai is also a fantastic poker player
and he taught us
he taught us a lot about his skills and
we were very passionate about
the behavioral economics behind it and
during the games
he would tell us a lot of stories and
and a lot of inspiration and when i'm
thinking back to
you know why why i'm so excited about
technology and why i'm why i was so
excited as a kid following this journey
i think that that was a huge part of it
it's seeing also from the background
like what
like it's real it's not just in the
headlines in the papers and
these the challenges are really uh are
really tangible
and and at the end everybody's just a
human being and and we try to move the
needle
and and i'm sure that you have such
incredible fulfillment from from knowing
that
you really did move the needle and it's
one of israel's most courageous
innovation innovative stories
ever since its founding i think it's
just remarkable aliza
i want to thank you for being so
generous with your time 20 minutes go by
very very quickly uh but uh but
unfortunately we
the show is called 20 minute leaders i
should have called it an hour minute
leaders
but before we leave i have to ask you
the most difficult question
and which is three words that you would
use to describe yourself and feel free
to answer it however however you feel
well maybe maybe i can be a little bit
generous with the definition of three
like a good israeli and negotiate with
you uh there you go
yeah i think um wow that's hard um
i'll take a stab and i'm sure it's not
it's not the real
or the only but then but it's the ones
come to mind i think that um not
necessarily in order of priority
i think is um in in a not
self-proclaiming way but i think it's
something about
integrity and authenticity would be my
first
in terms of um i really do
speak my mind and sometimes people don't
even like it but
what i really really speak my mind
and i walk my talk i try very hard to
walk my talk
[Music]
so i think the second one which might be
related
is is um is courage
and the countries and the courage
is um is um
it's not the same courage as as the the
visioneer
i didn't you know it's not the courage
of thinking
uh how i'm going to change the world
it's not that kind of courage
um but it's definitely the courage of
being with people like that not knowing
necessarily where payroll will come
tomorrow and with
so dealing with with the fears and
uncertainties of a startup
that that's an easier courage the
courage that i think that i
that i possess is really not good of
ramifications
of me doing the right thing my
confidence about
my beliefs about doing the right thing
whatever ramifications will bring
i think that's courage and i've and i
wouldn't have known that but i've heard
people tell me that
because so i think that that's a kind of
courage you know
knowing that if you you know this will
bring you get you into trouble
um this will um you may lose your job
you may fall out of favor with someone
but i think there's
there's something um it was wonderful
until now elisa
the walking the talk it's it's
i think not enough people do it and i
think it's that
that courage of actually executing on
your intentions and we talked about
being intentional a lot
and i loved when you when you brought up
the walk the talk with that first word
and with integrity because it's it's
it's own world in itself
and i think that having knowing that
there's somebody that
knowing somebody that you can trust that
you can trust that person and that you
can really believe
that they'll walk whatever they'll do
whatever they say they'll do not
necessarily
they'll do it right or 100 but but that
they'll actually be intentional in doing
it
and to me that that's what trust is
about that's what partnership is about
so
so if it's okay with you i'll take that
as the third word
oh great i actually wanted to add a
different one but i'm happy to
it it's a derivative but that's but
that's perfect
that's perfect i love it aliza thank you
very very much this was inspiring and
thoughtful
and a lot more uh so thank you for
giving me the time
and and i look forward to thank you very
much
yeah thank you for the opportunity it's
been a lot of fun and now you owe me a
cup of coffee
you